thyroid disorders affect an estimated 20
million people in the U.S but a lot of
people still have questions about what
the thyroid's function is and how to
treat problems January is thyroid
awareness month and here to answer some
of our questions is Dr chard Bob from
Intermountain Healthcare Dr Bob thank
you for being here thank you for having
me what is the function of the thyroid
the thyroid is uh primarily responsible
for metabolism in the body so it's very
important for the brain to work the hard
to work and for muscles to actually
function properly and also to keep us
warm so whenever you have a low thyroid
State commonly you have trouble
maintaining your temperature so you tend
to feel cold you could also have like
weakness and it could create some like
some degree of mental fog and who is
most likely to have problems with their
thyroid women have five to ten times
more likely to have thyroid dysfunction
compared to men also there's really no
commonly you can see it in infants and
also in postmenopausal women so it
actually affects you know regardless of
gender or age you can actually see
thyroid dysfunction in whichever age
group you look at and you have
hypothyroid thyroidism and
hyperthyroidism what's the difference
between correct so in hypothyroidism the
thyroid is on the functioning so it's
not making enough thyroid hormone which
is called thyroxine primarily and then
hyperthyroidism it makes too much okay
so there on the screen we have the
hypotherism symptoms yes so commonly uh
with hypothyroidism weight gain will be
common difficulty in regulating
temperature for tea also muscle weakness
brain fog dry skin thinning of the hair
also constipation so there are some of
the common symptoms seen in
hypothyroidism and hyperthyroidism and
hypothyroidism is the opposite so one
will have rapid heart rate also
tightness it will also increase body
movement and it could also have once
have degree in anxiety or difficulty
sleeping so as a result it would be the
opposite of what you see in a low
thyroid state so a lot of people may
have some of the symptoms we've talked
about how does one find out if it is
indeed something to do with a thyroid
definitely you started in terms of
contacting your provider and they can
actually do some testing one of the
common tests that we do is a test called
thyroid stimulating hormone it's a
hormone that's secreted by the pituitary
gland which is a gland in the brain and
that test can tell because if that test
is low then what that means is that that
person actually has an overproduction of
thyroid hormone on the other hand that
if that TSH test comes back high it
suggests that other person like me has
an underactive thyroid so that would be
a screening test and then the additional
testing that can be done to confirm and
then the treatments begin thank you Dr
Chad so much for being here appreciate
your time and we want to thank
Intermountain Healthcare for sponsoring
this segment if you want more
information on this just visit
intermountainhealthcare Dot org forward
slash Nevada we'll be right back